merci merci beaucoup pour ces réponses
précis je vais peut-être donner la
parole maintenant à bernard gérard qui a
fait un rapport très important sur le
sur les relations avec avec l'urssaf
on n'est pas au coeur des problématiques
de droit du travail mais enfin on étend
l'application et dans l'applicabilité
des choses dont tu peux tu nous en dire
plus oui merci beaucoup donc l'accueil a
dit jeu de va voilà qui était à
l'assemblée sur une ppl et qui nous
parlera du rsi oui effectivement il y a
de plus en plus de règles qui sont créés
par le législateur mais également de
plus en plus d'exception est le
corollaire de l'exception c'est le
contrôle et donc effectivement la
mission qui m'avait été confiée était
absolument passionnante l'idée de
refonder les relations entre
l'entreprise et l'urssaf 67 % des
entreprises en france sont contrôlés
bénéficient de bénéficient d'un contrôle
urs à 60% d'entre elles sont redressés
12% d'entre elles reçoivent de l'argent
de l'urssaf parce qu'elles ont eu trop
payés c'est dire à quel point
eh bien il est difficile d'appliquer de
les règles et dans le maquis des textes
qui existent de s'y retrouver dans le
cadre de la mission qui m'a été confiée
j'ai rencontré de nombreuses personnes
notamment un chef d'entreprise qui me
disaient j'ai racheté trois entreprises
en france j'ai eu trois contrôle fiscal
et trois contrôles fiscaux étroit
contrôle urssaf
j'ai racheté une entreprise en allemagne
j'ai eu aussi un contrôle urssaf et là
j'en ai vraiment eu marre j'ai dit aux
contrôleurs urssaf allemand mais qu'est
ce que vous venez me voir
vous vous n'en voulez pas du tout on dit
les contrôleurs de l'urssaf en allemagne
nous ne venons pas pour vous faire un
redressement nous venons vous dire
puisque vous avez racheté une entreprise
nous sommes là nous sommes à votre
disposition nous sommes là pour vous
conseiller et donc toute l'idée qui a
sous-tendu et leur le rapport que j'ai
écrit avec mon collègue marc goua a
consisté à dire comment faire en sorte
que l'urssaf devienne une administration
plus évidente que puni sentent le terme
n'est pas péjoratif mais je pense que
c'est extrêmement important et c'est
vrai que il faut d'abord lutter contre
ce principe devenu complètement faux nul
n'est censé ignorer la loi
nul n'est censé contre connaître toute
la loi aujourd'hui c'est impossible et
donc compte tenu de ce
1 d'abord nous avons travaillé sur le
rescrit puisque le rescrit est une
manière de faciliter la vie des
entreprises et nous avons proposé trois
sortes de rescrit et ça a été d'ailleurs
accepté le rescrit individuel poser une
question à l'administration disant voilà
moi je vois ça quelle est la règle
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire et donc
répondez-nous le rescrit individuel au
rescrit par branches aussi parce que
quand il ya une branche et bien
d'activité et qu'ils aient envie de
savoir pour l'ensemble de ses adhérents
et bien ce qu'il faut faire il est
normal de proposer qu'il ait une réponse
collective et troisièmement le rescrit
ouvert aux tiers déclarant que sont par
exemple les experts comptables qui sont
au coeur de l'actualité financière comme
des avocats d'ailleurs ou juridique de
l'entreprise et qui ont besoin d'être
renseigné mais ça ne suffit pas ce qu'il
faut aussi si on veut simplifier les
choses si on veut améliorer les
relations entre donc l'état et et son
administration
il faut aussi que ces rescrit soit
publiée et qu'il y ait comme en matière
fiscale d'ailleurs un bulletin qui
permettent de connaître quelle est en
quelque sorte la jurisprudence donc des
urssaf en france et qu'il y ait
véritablement l'information la plus
complète possible
et puis pour être court parce qu'il ya
44 mesures qui ont été proposées un
certain nombre d'entre elles ont été
déjà retenu d'autres me dit-on seront
sans doute présenté au plfss mais sinon
je me ferai fort avec mes collègues amis
de présenter un certain nombre
d'amendements la bonne foi doit être
aussi reconnue et en matière de
complémentaire santé ou en matière
d'allègement dit notamment l'allègement
fillon
eh bien il convient de faire en sorte
que ce ne soit pas le tout ou rien il
n'est pas possible d'avoir une
entreprise qui au prétexte qu'elle a
fait une erreur soit pénalisée sur
l'ensemble de la masse salariale avec
des pénalités qui sont absolument hors
de portée hors de proportion par rapport
à la faute éventuelle qui a pu être
causé si elle est de bonne foi
on doit simplement essayé d'appliquer la
pénalité sur l'erreur qui a été commise
et non pas sur la totalité de ce qui a
été fait et donc on est en vraiment en
dialogue sur ce sujet je
ce père que ce rapport est bien sera
appliqué dans sa totalité parce que je
pense que bon il ya un certain nombre de
mesures qui sont tout simplement des
mesures de bon sens et qui sont le
reflet de ce qu'ont dit les entreprises
qui ont besoin aujourd'hui de retrouver
du dialogue tant au sein de l'entreprise
qu'avec les administrations voilà